Now we'll
discuss Judaism in the right perspective
to
understand the concept of God in
Judaism. It's mentioned in the Old
Testament in the book of
Deuteronomy chapter number 6 verse
number four. Moses peace be upon him
says it's a Hebrew quotation which means
y Israel the lord our god is one
lord it's mentioned in the book of
Isaiah chapter number 43 verse number 11
I even I am lord and besides me there is
no
savior it's mentioned in the book of
Isaiah chapter number 45 verse number
I am Lord and there is none else. There
is no God besides me. It's mentioned in
the book of Isaiah chapter number
46. Verse number
nine. I am God and there's none else. I
am God and there's none like
me. It further mentioned in the book of
Exodus chapter number 20 verse number 3
to 5.
Thou shalt have no other gods before me.
Thou shalt not make unto thee any grim,
any graven image of anything of any
likeness in the heaven above, in the
earth beneath, in the water under the
earth. Thou shall not b onto them nor
serve them. For I, thy God, thy Lord is
a generous
God. The same message is repeated in the
book of Deuteronomy chapter number five
verse number 7-9.
where it says, "Thou shalt have no other
god besides me." Thou shalt have no
other gods before me. Thou shalt not
make unto thee any graven image of
anything of any likeness in the heaven
above, in the earth beneath, in the
water beneath the earth. Thou shalt not
bow onto them, nor serve them. For I,
thy God, thy Lord is a jealous God.
So if you read the scriptures of
Judaism, if you read the Old Testament,
if you read the Torah, you shall
understand the concept of God in Judaism
and understand Judaism in the right
perspective.